BENEDICT CUMBERBATCH
Hey, everyone!
We are the cast of Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness.
ELIZABETH OLSEN
We're all really proud of this film,
and so appreciative of your support.
BENEDICT WONG
It's a story that will connect
the MCU in new dimensions
you never thought possible.
XOCHITL GOMEZ
With maddening twists
that'll having you wracking
your brain for answers.
DOCTOR STRANGE
Okay...
BENEDICT WONG
The moment you've been waiting for
is almost here.
ELIZABETH OLSEN
Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness
will be available on Disney Plus,
starting June 22nd.
DOCTOR STRANGE
What?
♪♪
WONG
Strange!
BENEDICT CUMBERBATCH
Get ready to experience
a Multiverse of madness.